Let's move ahead.
The next thing I want to do is supply
out NSURL session with a request.
But first, there are a few important
things that I want to point out.
What we've been calling requests,
the NSURL session refers to as tasks.
Also, any task used by NSURL session
is a sub class of NSURL session tasks.
Let's break that down.
There are three main tasks that we can
work with, data task, download task, and
upload task.
A data task, or
an NSURLSession data task, returns
data from the network directly into
memory as one or more NS data objects.
The key word for
remembering this type of task is data.
Data tasks are good for
short lived requests, and
we'll be using them
exclusively in this course.
A download task, or
NSURL session download task,
returns data from the network
into a temporary file.
Think of these tasks like downloading
a file from the Internet,
when the task completes you
have a file to work with.
And finally, the upload task,
or NSURL upload session task.
These kinds of tasks are specialized for
uploading content.
Like I said, in this course we're
just going to focus on data task.
To recap,
in the code we have the image URL and
we have the shared NSURL session.
So, now we're ready to make our request,
or a task in this case.
To create an NSURL session data task,
we need to use the NSURL sessions
method called data task with URL.
We'll be using the version of this
method that takes the URL and
a closure called a completionHandler and
it returns a NSURLSession data task.
So I'll go ahead and capture the return
value, which is the task, and
then I'll specify our imageURL.
And now let's talk about
the completionHandler.
The completionHandler is
just like any other closure.
It's named completionHandler because
it's executed after the data task
completes and we can't really
be sure when that will happen.
The task might complete
in a few milliseconds, or
it might take a whole minute.
But that's the real
power of this closure.
It's like us saying I don't really know
when this task is going to complete, but
when it does run this block of code.
Now instead of using this closure,
we could use NSURL session's family of
delegates to handle running code
after the task completes but
we won't be doing that in this course.
If you're interested, I'll post links
in the instructor notes that cover
the NSURL session
delegates in more detail.
Now this completion handler
takes three parameters.
The types of those parameters are NS
data, NS URL response, and NS error.
Now if you haven't seen those
types before, don't worry.
We'll slowly introduce them.
For their local parameter names I'll
call them data, response, and error.
For now let's ignore all of them and
try printing task finish
when the task completes.
And we'll build and run this.
Hm, well,
it doesn't appear to be working because
our print statement isn't showing up.
Let's talk about why this is next.